“Good” is a really subjective term, and
we all have our individual preferences when
we go to the movies.
So when it’s time to decide what to watch,
everyone’s criteria is a little different.
Wether it’s because of box office bank,
critical acclaim, or a general audience consensus,
here are 10 Famous Actors With Only One Good
Movie Performance.
Daniel Radcliffe - Harry Potter and the Deathly
Hallows: Part II
To some people, the proof about if a movie
is “good” or not lies in the amount of
money it brings in at the box office.
If that’s true, then Harry Potter and the
Deathly Hallows: Part II is the best movie
Daniel Radcliffe has ever done.
It’s one of the highest grossing movies
of all time, and none of his other roles have
gotten anywhere close to the same amount of
attention.
We know that fanbase size isn’t the best
way to judge quality, but in this case the
masses are actually right.
It’s Radcliffe’s best role.
Even JK Rowling approves, and she invented
the character.
Jessica Alba - Sin City
The people of Basin City are a rare breed.
Everything about them is just a little more
dramatic.
And thanks to Frank Miller, they’re eloquent
and tough as hell.
2005’s Sin City brought a huge ensemble
cast together and delivered an experience
like we’d never seen.
The movie is visually stunning, and will supply
more than enough story to keep you entertained.
It’s a shame we can’t say that about the
rest of Jessica Alba’s movies.
The actress isn’t known for her acting chops,
but she argues that it’s hard to give a
good performance when the material sucks.
Point: Alba.
Orlando Bloom - The Lord of the Rings franchise
When Orlando Bloom came on the scene as Legolas
in 2001, the Lord of the Rings actor got a
lot of attention.
But teenage girls weren’t the only ones
swooning.
Even the franchise’s diehard fans were pleased
with the casting.
Everyone’s favorite woodland elf has some
of the most badass moments in the entire series.
And Bloom does it well.
But life after Legolas has been less awesome,
and so have the actor’s movie choices.
This doesn’t mean he hasn’t made any money
though.
But even in Pirates of the Caribbean, he’s
outshined by Johnny Depp at very turn.
Cameron Diaz, The Mask
For someone who’s played a range of different
characters, Cameron Diaz’s work has started
blending together over the last decade or
so.
The actress has starred in multiple rom-com
flops, and been the very recognizable voice
of Princess Fiona in the Shrek franchise.
But there’s one performance that sticks
with us until this very day, from her breakout
role in The Mask.
1994 was a long time ago, so if the Jim Carrey
classic is a little hazy in your mind, we
recommend that you give it another viewing.
Especially since it’s Diaz’s best.
John Travolta - Pulp Fiction
Disco does not have a reputation for being
cool.
And even though John Travolta had all the
right moves in Saturday Night Fever, the movie
has some inescapably cheesy elements.
So when Quentin Tarantino offered him the
role of Vincent Vega in 1994’s Pulp Fiction,
the actor took the opportunity to shake his
dorky disco image for good.
The director must foster a creative environment
on set, because Travolta’s at his best.
And while he seemed to be everywhere in the
nineties, none of his other work is as memorable
or iconic.
Mila Kunis - Black Swan
Mila Kunis has been on television since she
was a kid.
But really grabbed everyone’s attention
when she landed the role of Jackie on That
70’s Show, and has been the voice behind
Meg on Family Guy.
While small-screen success is powerful in
it’s own right, it doesn't guarantee victory
at the box office.
And the actress has talked about how embarrassed
she is of some of her roles.
But her turn as Lily in Black Swan is not
one of them.
As a supporting character, Kunis totally stole
the show, and a lot of critical acclaim.
But then Jupiter Ascending happened, and everyone
forgot.
Marlon Wayans - Requiem for a Dream
Requiem for a Dream is not an easy movie to
watch.
It’s heavy story and dark atmosphere are
specifically designed to throw viewers off
balance.
So obviously Darren Aronofsky is the perfect
person to direct it.
And while audiences were confident about the
man behind the camera, they were surprised
to see Marlon Wayans in front of it.
Yep, the guy from In Living Color and Scary
Movie.
His comedic background made him seem like
an odd choice for such a humorless film, but
Wayans nails the performance.
But the accolades end there, since he also
starred in White Chicks.
Lindsay Lohan - Mean Girls
When a star’s personal life becomes public
knowledge, it has the potential to overshadow
their work.
And it’s easy to forget how talented someone
is when their mugshot is constantly being
shoved in your face.
Take, for example, Lindsay Lohan.
A string of DUI’s and sub-par career choices
have made her a punchline.
But in 2004, the team behind Mean Girls knew
what they were doing when they cast Lohan
as the lead.
Working with comedic heavy-hitters Tina Fey,
Amy Poehler and Tim Meadows, the actress held
her own and brought a lot of genuine innocence
to a movie full of backstabbing.
Cuba Gooding Jr. - Jerry Maguire
Another way people measure an actors success
is to look at the trophies on their mantle.
And if you’re one of those people, then
as far as you’re concerned, Cuba Gooding
Jr. has only been in one good movie.
But after winning an Oscar for his performance
in Jerry Maguire, the actor got in his own
way.
In the afterglow of his win, he turned down
a few roles that would have been huge.
When he was ready to come back to showbiz,
the offers stopped coming.
Well, not ALL the offers stopped, just the
good ones.
Kate Hudson - Almost Famous
As the daughter of Goldie Hawn, Kate Hudson
knew that if she was going to be an actress,
she had some high stilettos to fill.
And when she transformed into Penny Lane for
2000’s Almost Famous, she succeeded.
Her performance was interesting and dynamic.
And even though she’s not the main character,
she’s easily the most nuanced.
After, despite her obvious talent, Hudson
was cast in a string of fluffy and forgettable
romantic comedies.
Where her characters are reduced to generic
tropes.
But hey, if Matthew McConaughey’s career
can recover from How to Lose a Guy in 10 Days,
maybe hers can too.
What do you think of our list?
Did we miss any other famous actors with only
one good performance in a movie?
Tell us about them in the comments, and subscribe
to our YouTube channel for more videos like
this one.